since we're here and I'm playing in the
club championship let's look at one of
my victories should we look at the one
that I like or the one I really like but
I can't remember either game oh yeah I
can okay so which one do I remember
better now neither one all right well
look at the game where I was black
because that had a funny ending to it
something I've never seen before it had
a double pin double fork at the same
time I've never seen that although he
resigned before I did it ah now two
pieces were pinned to the King and they
were both forked and so I'm going to win
both of them usually when you fork a
piece you win one of them I wouldn't
boast
okay so d4 which is unusual one kid's
class would have a mouse awesome c4 now
this is called the Benoni
when black plays east six and if black
plays b5 that pawns hanging it's free
that's called the Banco gambit the Banco
game was named after who mr. gambit now
Benko and Banco is a strong American
player from Hungary who's the strongest
player from Hungary living in st. Louis
some of you have heard of her notice I
said her mmm little hint there yeah ah
I mean well if Magnus lived here that
would be correct if he was from Hungary
but he doesn't live here and he's from
Norway although the last class never
heard of him so the correct answer is
Susan Polgar
if they heard her know nothing you got
nothing
oh well thanks to a regularly scheduled
program okay so I played e5 which is
blocking everything up look how blocked
this is nobody can do anything right so
can we play in the center and move our
pawns forward and this
now now so we better do something else
okay so I moved my bishop and I move my
knight and now he wants to open up the
center so he played f4 he's attacking
the center that's not very nice is it
now I wanted to take a free pawn but
then he would take my Knight and I would
cry so I pinned his night so I
threatened to take the pawn how did I
pin this Knight
how did I pin that night yes uh wait
what you i play Queen to a5 now the
knight can't move because he'd be in
check what kind of pin is that yes
somebody absolutely right okay now my
opponent didn't want to lose upon but
Queen e5 is a bit tricky you know why
it's tricky if he unpinned with his
Bishop which looks sort of normal then I
would take his pawn and normally he
takes with the bishop but then he's
pinned again haha okay but he didn't
fall for that
unfortunately so he played Queen to c2
defending his pawn that wasn't very nice
of him so I castled because I like
castling and he played f5 blocking up
the center again it's like we're both
playing checkers on different colors now
how did I bust through in the center the
answer is I didn't because the center is
blocked so I played b5 and I thought he
would take my pawn and I would open it
up over there but he played g4 he wants
to play g5 which is really mean and I
played B for attacking his Knight and
his Knight went here and I played b3 and
if I was playing one of you guys I would
be doing quite well here because you
probably would make a mistake now and
then I would start taking things then I
go to the emergency room hurting my arm
taking all your pieces right that's
likely so if you were white what would
you
here yes two partial credit
yes yeah ah
practice your wines last night yeah
if King to F 2 then pawn takes Queen
gives black the advantage agreed we can
all agree on that right I was hoping for
that but no you Queen the c3 is correct
if Queen to d2 which also saves the
Queen I take the Queen and then I take
my pawn I was trying to take like ten
moves ago okay so he played Queen to c3
now if I trade Queens he takes with the
night and his knight defends his pawn I
hate when that happens
my computer says I should play Queen to
b4 but I played Bishop to d8 defending
my queen and I'm attacking this pawn
right I can't take the pawn right away
because you'll take my Queen for free so
I defended my queen first now he made a
good move so I got really mad and I
called the director I said come on you
know this guy he can't make a good move
we all agreed and he'd take it back
no he played Bishop to d2 the best move
now he's really attacking my queen he's
not kidding so I moved my queen away and
if he takes this pawn then I would take
his rook so that I think that's good for
black okay so he didn't do that also I
want to take this pawn here remember
I'll attack it for like ten moves so he
played Knight f2 and defended it and
then I took this pawn yay now that pawns
gonna Queen and I win right now you just
went he took it and then I cried he
played Queen b3 attacking my pawn I
played Bishop a5 he took my pawn and I
attacked his Queen so he moved his Queen
away
and I took his Bishop she take my bishop
or should he take my queen we get a
little of everything
Bishop Queen he can't take the Queen
those were three answers two of those
answers are right okay Queen takes Queen
was not allowed to the computer let me
do it computers like no you can't do
that because he's in check so he took my
bishop now I took his queen and he made
a small error but it's understandable he
should take with the rook which gives
this pawn away but then his rook is
really really really good
it'll probably win my pawn later instead
he took with a pawn and now his rook is
not good now his rook is behind upon the
whole game how about my rook yay open
file right yeah okay
so I played Bishop a6 putting pressure
on this pawn and now he started playing
badly the computer says this position is
about equal but then he made like 10 bad
moves in a row that it wasn't equal
anymore okay so he played Bishop to d3
which is not good because his bishop
already moved he should get his Knight
out I attacked his pawn how did he
defend his pawn on c4 what did he do
I'm going to take with the bishop I'm
going to take with the knight how did
he'd protect his pawn yes with the rook
that's correct then I played Knight here
so my rook can come in and he played
Knight here and I attacked his pawn I
thought I did I attacked his part there
we go you see his pawn that's attacked
what did he do about it how did he
protect his pawn he made the longest
move ever you need like a corrective eye
surgery to see this move it's so long
yes
rook a1 did I take his pawn now it
sacrificed my rook now I played my other
rook to the open file hooray
now he made a mean move so I called the
director again raised my hand right and
he played Knight c1 why did he do that
threaten my rook did I see it
yeah I played here now if he takes my
rock I take with my ruck and replace it
so he played here then I put him in
check
I thought those rook that rook was
pretty silly as I went here now that
rook can't move
I showed him so he played h3 and he said
you can't beat me I'm just going to sit
here ok now I did something really good
I'm winning on the B file because I said
so
you see how I have the B file and he
doesn't
is there another open file the answer is
no there are no other open files so I
have to make an open file ok you go to
the grocery store and you buy the right
ingredients that you make an open file
right then if you take it to prison you
can break out because you have an open
file right nothing you got nothing right
and some of you kids better learn that
ok so I have an open file on the
queenside I want to open a file on the
Kings side that's not easy it took me
like four moves I could have had like a
period end instead of getting four moves
ah green water I don't leave my carbon
footprint so I played g5 and my plan is
to play h5 and then open the H file if I
play h5 now then he'll play g5 and
everything's closed up then I can't open
a file so I play g5 and I have no idea
what he did so I'll pretend I did
he played King to e3 I think then I
played King g7 and then I played rook AJ
and finally I played h5 hurry for me and
then I took and now I have another open
file now I pinned his Knight because he
likes with his Knights pinned ok and he
did something not seriously he did what
did he do or ok one that's right ok then
I poured he play King e2
yeah then I played rook here and he
played Bishop to d1 and I played Knight
to b6
and the reason I played Knight b6 is I
want to take this pawn okay and boy he's
in a lot of trouble now
he actually there's nothing he can do
about it so he cried a little bit I
called the director the director cried -
okay because I kept calling the director
over you he could but I have a bishop
and a knight on it I got two pieces on
that point okay so he played a four and
here's what he was thinking I'll tell
you what he was thinking I was thinking
Arby's he was thinking Knight takes
check rook takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes rook that's what he was thinking
okay so I took with the bishop now if he
takes I or he plays this terrible move
now if he takes I play Knight takes rook
check
he can't take my rook because he's in
check so he didn't like that so he
played what did he play he played Bishop
f3 now what did he play played something
a5 that's what he played and then I took
his Knight threatening his rook so he
took my Bishop and now every move wins
but I could only play one move because
that's all you're allowed to play so I
played rook h3 check now he's down a
pawn and his Knight and her king or sort
of attacked on both you know what I mean
okay so he resigned which was
unfortunate because here's what I wanted
to do I thought he would block with his
Bishop and then I was going to play
Knight takes pawn Shaq what do you think
he would do
take my night and then a tactic I've
never seen before Eve for forking to
pieces that are both pin to the king
that I'll show him and I win both of
them
you can't save one I get them both right
unless you can find out a way to save
them partial credit yes they're both
pinned and they're both forked I wanted
to teach pins and Forks today so that
was the best example I could find King
to where King D for my computer only
play that it moves it back to e3 because
that would be illegal wait what who well
this is the league all King here then my
knight would take his King so that would
be unethical
yes King to e2 then I do another fork
yay
then I win more pieces that I really do
at the really emergency room because I
take it all those pieces hurts but he
didn't let me to do that he gave up that
wasn't nice of him I'm trying I'm trying
to take his pieces here here right then
I would play rook takes Knight Shaq you
would move your king again then I would
take your Bishop what I have three
choices Wow it's too bad that didn't
happen that have been cool okay so in
this position he gave up his Kings not
too safe my rooks are a little better
than his and I'm a pawn up and I'm
winning a piece I sort of like my
position okay that was my game two days
ago right I can show you game I played
in 1989 but don't want to see that okay
Anand was world champion before Carlsen
you agree who was the last person an on
beat in a world championship match
before he played Carlsen then they're
like how he beat somebody right he beat
someone who did he beat his first name
is Boris he's from Israel that helped
yes well that's a
answer boris spassky would have been
right 45 years ago but not now
yeah anyone Bueller okay the correct
answer is Boris Gelfand your favorite
player well he is now because I'm going
to show you to get my beat of 1989 so
okay so we played your favorite opening
an Enzo Indian okay
and you'll notice white's knight is
pinned
so where did i move my knight nowhere
but i protected it that's pretty good
well i remember this game was played
1989 ah okay hey when you learn math
problems when you were like for like one
plus one how do you remember them i was
like years ago you learned that I don't
get it okay how do you remember your
name you were named years and years and
years ago I remember I remember my kids
names how do you remember your own name
who you have a question I have an answer
the knight wasn't pinned so what you're
saying is my knight could have moved
here but the computer won't let me it's
a mean computer right because then he
would take my king okay so my opponent
played pawn here attacking my pawn on d4
so first I cried then then I figure I'll
do something about it I remember I cried
99s it's pretty good okay so I took on
c5 and he played Queen here which is a
strange move and then the sort of boring
in the opening there was a really
exciting move played in the middle game
very are you guys excited so he put all
his pawns on the third rank very
suspicious but he did it I couldn't stop
him okay and we got this position so
just like when you play chess both sides
have all of their minor pieces out we
have two knights and two bishops and we
move them all out that's what you guys
do right
okay and I Castle that he didn't castle
but we're going to vote you can vote for
kingside castling for black you could
vote for queenside castling or you could
vote for buchanan okay it's all good
who votes kingside castling who says
queenside well you guys all be world
champions like Gelfand because he played
queenside castling and obviously if you
cannon wins right obviously okay so he
Castle queenside that's the losing move
that's a terrible move okay he should
Castle kingside where's King is safe
okay now after the game I went to
Laurence Olivier and I said what do you
think of this King side castling and he
said is it safe and I said yeah and he
said is it safe and I said yeah and he
said is it safe how are we going to get
sued by them or no we're good we're good
look they won't see us okay good okay
alright so castling queenside very
suspicious somebody raised their hand
even you at home I'll see you and tell
me why did but when you Castle why do
you castle what's your reasoning because
your teacher told you to what's good
about castling yes yeah your King is
safer when you castle and your rook that
stuck in the corner gets too caught in
the middle I don't think his King is
safer when he moved all his Queen side
pawns his Kings side he didn't move any
of his pawns
so my king is safe okay but his King
looks like he might have to eat some
diamonds later we're still not going to
get sued right okay no you promised okay
good
okay so this is called opposite side
castling it's called that because we
castle on opposite sides well named
i castle here he cancelled over there
when that happens we usually see pawn
storms okay they're sort of like
snowstorms but they're more dangerous
okay so pawn stars means you move all
the pawns towards your opponent's king
if you cancel on the same side and you
do that then your King gets exposed
if you cancel opposite sides your king
is still safe when you do that so if I
move all my pawns towards this king my
king is still safe so we did a pawn
storm okay so I played b4 I remember it
like it was yesterday okay then my
opponent attacked my Bishop like I'm
nobody
well he knew who I was pretty well okay
and I move my Bishop here notice I'm
attacking this pawn and I got two rooks
to back it up so he played a five what's
the only safe square for the bishop yes
so I did that then he played g5 he's
going to do a part but I'm going to do a
pawn storm then he put his rook over
here like I'm afraid of his rooks
against my King am I afraid of that a
little okay now I got a bust open his
King I can't do it slow because he'll
checkmate me he's Boris Gelfand I'm
nobody
so I played a5 and he said thank you
then I played c5 now I'm opening up his
King and he didn't like that so what did
he do he cried and then he tried to
checkmate my king
so I forked his Queen and Bishop he took
I took and he took my knight
now his rook is open against my king but
my bishop is blocking yay and instead of
taking this pawn I took this pawn yeah
that was better then we traded and he
took this pawn
notice if my knight moves away he'll
take my Queen so did I move my knight
away my knight is pinned okay so did I
resign because I'm gonna lose my knight
no it's his king nice and safe with lots
of funds in front of it what about my
king
lots of pawns okay so I played four
tricks you know I played four tricks
because tricks are for kids
Brook hey a check raise your hand if you
know how to count how many legal moves
how many possible moves does black have
how many different legal moves is what
how many moves can black mate to get out
of check so like five one five those are
your answers are quite odd one three and
five all right raise your hand you get
to say an answer what three is correct
you can you can play knight here Queen
here or King here now two of those moves
lose a queen he didn't want to lose his
Queens he didn't do those moves this
room obviously loses a queen because I
take it this move it's not so obvious
it's actually very tricky now I would a
queen with a skewer followed by a fork
and the last time I did that I was at a
Greek restaurant no I I didn't get the
lamb if I did it would be a bad joke yes
don't look so sheepish yes what's this
guy saying over here yes you wait you're
right
you feeling okay that's right
okay seven check notice how it's a
skewer so I sort of gave it away then he
would take my rook right right and then
I would go here and then I would win
yay hurry for me so he doesn't like
losing his Queens he didn't do that so
he played nine to be eight now I
unpinned my knight and I got another
piece to attack his King how did I
unpaid my knight and attack his King and
I really attacked his King I put it in
check that's it that's attacking his
King anyone Bueller not bathrooms over
there yes
in a circle got dizzy you know why I do
that a lot I'm the rotating GM yeah and
you want yeah Queen where Queen B - I
don't think that's check let me check
no I double check that it wasn't check
yes that's risky it's risky also it
doesn't unpin my night bathroom still
down there you in the back Queen f5 is
correct check now I'm not pinned anymore
and he's in shock and this still loses
the Queen which I just showed you so now
he made your favorite move he resigned
you guys are used to that right that
happens a lot uriens if he doesn't
resign he has to go here because
otherwise you have to resign then I
would go Bishop takes pawn you would
take my bishop and I go checkmate
true story notice how the Knights pinned
or or you could move your queen and then
I have to checkmates I could sack my
queen and then mate or if I don't want
to sack my Queen which I do I could set
my rook and then mate notice how all of
my pieces are attacking his King which
has no pawns in front of it my King has
a lot of puns in front of it and this
rook was really active right terrible
terrible that's the worst thing you ever
saw okay now I'll show you my favorite
game that was played this well actually
it's 2014 so I was played last year at
this very chess club but not in this
room it was two floors up now as you
know the best college in the world not
academically but for chess is I'll give
you a hint it's in Webster Groves
but reversing in Korea that's correct
webs Webster has ten grandmasters going
to that school and some of them were
upstairs right now
okay and some of the best in the world
okay now one of the guys who goes to
that school he's their board for he I
played him in well let's say April or
May since I don't remember let's say
April okay
and this was the game we had if you
remember the game I just showed you and
you don't
it started out this way didn't it I have
an answer what is this boy interrupted
why well I I just work here I I just
work here okay no so how would I know
okay
now in this position my opponent played
here and if you remember the last game
the guy did that remember that okay this
guy did this okay and then we developed
our pieces because we're the cool kids
okay then he didn't want to be pinned so
he unpinned he went here and then just
like my last opponent he put all his
pawns on the third-ranked but unlike my
last opponent he Castle kingside
so as not to get mated so I made it this
guy even worse actually I played the
other rook okay very similar okay now he
was afraid
don't touch the chess pieces they're
noisy he was afraid I was going to play
Knight year and Knight takes pawn which
I would have so he played a6 now the
theme of this game is overloaded or
overworked okay
and this is Sunday morning so sometimes
overloaded but this is overworked
because I'm working it so you see this
bishop that is now green it's envious or
the other bishop right nothing you got
nothing okay
it's defending this pawn and it's
defending and then this weird stuff just
happened at school it's defending this
Knight so can it move
play at the same time now so I took this
one Oh actually he played aged six
Bishop h4 which I forgot it's good
memory their age for Bishop II okay okay
now I took the night if he takes with
the bishop I have a free pawn he didn't
want to lose upon so what did he do
took with the pawn now his King is nice
and safe what would Laurence Olivier say
what Dustin Hoffman say okay so next
time you go to the dentist okay never
mind
so white play I play 94 attacking this
he played nine before attacking my queen
and attacking my knight where did I move
my queen where it's still protecting my
knight
yes b1 now his Knights attacking my pawn
but my Queens defending it and his
bishops are tagging my knight but my
Queens defending it
so my queen is overloaded so he took my
knight and I took his bishop and he said
yummy yummy free pawn but but that's
that's not Bob Segar wasn't talking
about that I know what that knight move
over there okay so all right you see a
four I haven't had one yet where is it
what yeah yeah who's he who's he he just
played Knight takes eight so he's gonna
move again don't I get some home if he
plays Knight c3 my pawn will take it
sporting your plans also it's not his
turn okay I played 9 to d4 and he
thought I was going to play Knight to c6
and he's right ok he should play Queen
d7 but he made the losing move making
the losing move is good in one instance
when you're playing me then it's okay
otherwise don't do it ok he played nine
to be for stopping knight c6 and getting
his night off of this awful square now I
give him the sugar
me do okay now his King ran all over the
board like this until he was dizzy then
when he passed out I went on time yes I
played nine take c6 because his F pawn
is overloaded his F pawn is defending
the ply just captured and the F pawn is
defending the g6 square although he has
to take by night because this is a
little for cure so he took my knight and
I played Czech now a few kids were
playing you would check back and forth
forever and start laughing okay that's
what would happen unfortunately but I
prefer winning that's the way I do it I
win
so I played Bishop to g4 and I'm going
to play Bishop takes e6 and Queen h6
mate with advantage how can he save his
East six pawn how does he do it
because this is going to win if I do
that by the way if he attacks my queen
mate so he didn't do that yeah yeah this
one that's the main variation he didn't
do that then I would go check check then
I would take this I'm threatening the
rook and I'm threatening me and my
computer says I'm plus five plus five is
good Plus Ones good but plus five is
better your move is about equally as
good as to what he did he played Queen
to d7 which also defends his pawn now I
made a move that's very shocking you
must be nine years old to see it I'll
wait if you're under nine you can leave
the room okay I played these the
crazy-looking move Bishop f5 notice how
it threatens checkmate checkmate is good
how did he stop Queen h7 mate what did
he do because he doesn't want to get
checkmated then he'd lose yeah
he did he did do that now if I could put
a rock on the H file that would be made
do you agree
so I played rugby for now if this if
this pawn moved his bishop would stop
the meat that's why I sacrificed my
bishop so that pawn can't move so he
moved this pawn and then he moved this
pawn now it's not make as he takes my
rook but I have another rook now I'm
going to play rook age for me and then
I'll win yay now he's got two ways to
stop it the right way in the wrong way
Shh he didn't see the right way he
played the wrong way the right way is
rook c7 which I showed him after check
takes takes here and the reason he
played rook c7 is the rook can take and
now I fork his rook in his Knight which
is worth more the rook so he saves his
rook and now White has a lot more pawns
than black I can't count how many as too
much but a lot more so he didn't like
this position and he didn't see this so
he played the obvious move to stop rook
h4 mate what can black do to protect
this h4 square the bishops protecting it
how can you protect it again in the back
correct
I said correct Queen to d8 now the
reason he play Queen to d8 was he said
he didn't see my next move but I saw my
next move okay all work on the H file is
checkmate except rook h4 because he
keeps protecting it so I played rook F 3
now we're cage threes checkmate okay
eventually so he played f4 to block my
rook that wasn't very nice of him now if
I check he'll play Bishop to h4 now I
played a shocking move you must be at
least nine and a half
okay I played rook takes d6
because his Queen and Bishop are
overloaded they're both defending h4
which stops the mate and they're both
defending the PI just took so if he
takes my ruck then check me hooray for
me right or as I would say checkmate
okay so he didn't like getting
checkmated so he played Bishop to h4 now
I have meat in five moves but I have a
good excuse for not playing it I didn't
see it
I played meat in seven mating five is
very easy check check check
and I didn't see Queen g6 otherwise I
would have played this now he's got one
legal move and then made that's how the
game should have ended but the way it
ended was funnier
I played Queen h5 check and then I
played Shak and then I played this check
now I think I have all my pieces
attacking what do you think also my king
is slightly safer than his Black has a
lot of legal moves but this is the only
one he resigned here now I have matin -
and there's 2 ways to do it who can find
mate in two moves there's two answers
yes Queen d6 he has to play here and
then mate with advantage the other mate
is this one now Black has zero King
moves that are legal zero is not a lot
so he has to play Knight d5 and then
maid
I'm not sure which man I would have
played he resigned before I could made
him
terrible well he was watching in the
1970s he's watching Nixon on television
he learned how to do it so I won yay so
in both games I used all my pieces to
attack not just one piece I didn't move
my queen on I moved to and try to make
my opponent before I moved it out okay
and then his King was unsafe because he
didn't have any pawns in front of it
conversely my King has a couple of pawns
in front of it all of them right so if
you're if you have pawns in front of
your King it's pretty safe if there's
nothing in front of your King not as
safe questions No okay now you can play
for a few minutes but don't play too
good because then your opponent might
cry